broccolini taking black guys on
airplanes huh and brown guys Wow yeah
black in brown you see my crown huh
Trump hates me haha build a wall around
your [ __ ] luggage I know how crazy
bro oh dude Isan is very dangerous to
travel with you get stopped every time
every time every no how about a fan this
girls that guy want to get a picture
the dude ghost not he's part of jihad
God he's Josh it was a dance series
nobody I'd like you know we took that
was like now he's part jaha we do that
[ __ ] dude I looked down my panel it I
get it I didn't do that what I can't
believe it I couldn't believe it
we're talking about Brennan's openers or
is uh as I like to refer to them as his
mauve twinks that he brings around the
country involves a color Brendon and
it's like a taupe kind of strong shades
of brown brown the guy the other
comedian his son he looks like a
librarian for al-qaeda bro looks like
al-qaeda's like an accountant and I know
he would laugh at that he likes good
jokes oh and I don't even know if that
is a good joke but I know he's okay if
we if we joke around I think Derek you
know him better than we do oh yeah he's
fine my little muzzle or Slims we call
him slim little slaves I've seen to me
bacon though oh yeah it's very good
thing a lot of these do
second-generation slams dude they're
Huff and pork at every chance they get
smoked pork bris oh it's Aaron dude you
wake him up in the middle of the night
and [ __ ] just pull their mouths open
and they got a thing of uh you know uh
Pig jerky and okay yeah did you kidnap
just put a nice slab of pork ribs in a
pan the song right in there that's what
I'm saying bro it's really interesting
how cuz i bite intro for one generation
people get hello
American rum you know what I'm saying
their parents have all like a lot of
like you know old school traditions but
you throw a [ __ ] couple hits a bake
on you give them that much in baby bad
hair back yeah and that's back in a baby
bag leave a little bit jump into that
van bro yeah they switch to the Lord
real quick bro you feel me doesn't
everybody
mmm good to be here man oh you got the
red jersey huh
yeah I got in Cincinnati bro Wow how
wrestling this is - I have no idea this
is Tommy Segura town
Tommy Segura bill yeah he's from
Cincinnati was from Cincinnati well not
a lot of people Gary Owen you know what
I think black Tom Segura yeah yeah same
guy but one's black he's like if there
were an underground railroad he would be
Tom Hanks and Polar Express
do you even up dude do not feel again
singing forever really yeah
you haven't seen me in in in in yeah I
guess I see last week I didn't see last
week on no what have I been up to dude
um I guess I'm just ended up
masturbating last night so I'm feeling
kind of I guess ashamed of my new so
what's going on man right when what
walked in I went the old bus nuts the
old bus someone you think that dude
yeah you could've think maybe my alarm
clock went off too early okay well you
immediately take your brain waves to my
balls you've never really that thick
sweat I thought some thick sweat came
out then ball sex because when he came
in your alarms on you put you in a bad
mood
you'd get over that okay British 35,000
other things I would think to consider
now but I can just tell kind of mood
you're like you're like my mood ring
really when you walk in you're my mood
ring oh thanks man
mmm it's pretty dark lately really
there's a dark mood ring well darkest
some would say I got my mood ring just
has bandwidth like a total band wagon
mood ring so every time it shows up with
you it's purple right now after sits
purple for the Raptors it just changed
to red and white for the Reds
it's got a couple if I look into her
right now
got a couple of marge schott recipes
just rolling through and I can even see
a pair of Chris Sabo goggles passing my
beautiful man
what is that in my mood ring right now
oh that's Brendon and Barry Larkin
holding hands and and also let's say be
honest Derek looks just like Barry
Larkin can we get a picture dare of very
Larkin up here Ozzy and let's see this
resemblance I hope he does otherwise I'm
gonna be some really racist same
complexion right yeah a little bit
that's awesome man good for you man
that's cool shut up - Barry Logica good
for you ropes out - very Larkin man oh
yeah what else what else has been going
on not too much dude um smoking cigs oh
I had a couple last night before bed
oh not any today man busting nuts and
say trust me it's gonna be a tough day
trust me 40 minutes of modern warfare
call of duty oh you're playing live now
yeah it's just an chad opened up a bunch
of snaps why did you do that deal bro
big tits people send me mail behold
everything all kind of things I don't
want I mean I want might you go down
that road I don't know what happened
it's the cigarettes I think one thing
kind of leads to the next and then it's
like it's 1:00 a.m. and I was planning
on going to bed at 10:00 p.m. dude and
then one am just playing call of duty
smoking them cigs yeah it just gets dark
and then tried to brush my teeth so that
was good and then um
what else you ever smoked a cigarette
wall playing call of duty live no
picture with the headstone I'm like even
a Seinfeld reenact like it is the same
plan yeah same memory Wow can't believe
you're allowed to leave your house with
with your brain every day is
baffling that is cigarettes busted nuts
in snapchat we got to keep an eye on man
trust me man you know it's getting risky
out here the streets are rough for the
Rat King the streets are rough for the
Rat King man it never ends bro there's
different levels man there's different
levels out there so but what else man
everything else is pretty much okay
really I'm trying to think I feel like
Oh something crazy happen but I can't
tell you on this show no no you okay
yeah I'm okay okay something bad I thing
about charging your 51 they might
charging my phone in a little while same
[ __ ]
Oh area 51 dude no you look like the
type dude who's gonna charge area 51
huh you look like the dude who's gonna
charge it oh I look like the dude is
gonna lead the charge you mean you know
what I'm saying all my freakin alien
honors dude everybody who wants to catch
them big eyed [ __ ] bad boys follow me
feel me big guy big eyes oh I know
there's two dead areas over there in
[ __ ] New Mexico guarantee probably 60
if you look in people's houses dude if
you don't but the shitty thing about an
alien is you get to it it just looks
like a like a stick of like kind of
white beef jerky with a couple raisins
at the end you know like couple raisin
eyes looks like a shitty snowman it's
not like Scully and Mulder have been
taking care of these fellas you know
it's it's a you know it's a it's a it's
you know it's the Air Force has been
taking care of him or whatever and I
don't think they've been trying to
really you know they're not nourished
and I'm just like to have them in there
and you know it get built-in Anytime
Fitness back there you never know they
might be working out they might be
feeding them ribs baby back ribs chili
baby back ribs
now you talking about illegal aliens
okay you're right and now you're on full
circle with our copper silver blanket
yeah bro put that hatch back up dude had
your back and baby back rib catch a new
opener and catch a freaking orbiter no
you got it all day everybody likes ribs
everybody in other countries Cat Cat you
like ribs yeah I love ribs
Asians love spareribs well you guys
liked uh you guys like the dry short
ribs right uh yeah it sounds like you
don't okay well you just accused them of
doing that well because you can get the
Korean short rib there
like dry and differents all Koreans have
their own ribs Chinese people have their
own ribs but you guys don't you guys
know like [ __ ] with like the Hickory
barbecue
I met how we making a box with damn
husky hitters boy she likes them big
boys on them sweet ribs hey what kind of
[ __ ] likes the beef ribs they're like
this big you have them in your body
going through a lot right now you just
start snapchat in your face cigarettes
in your lips well first of all people
need to start thinking about their about
their lives and if they have any
freaking if they have the Lord and then
before their start snapchat and others
it is sick sometimes we see an [ __ ]
though you see the Lord you that that's
the horse look at that you okay you know
you know what I call it living
uh-huh you need to start living till
dude get off line quit playing with kids
and call of duty you're too old for that
bro get a cigarette go through that
snapchat and jagoff okay that's a night
that's what a grown man does way to
guess what a grown man does you just
don't get off line and then get on
snapchat and play call of duty which
both things are wrong no not play call
dude give that [ __ ] up it's fun I
disagree with some of the military moves
that they made but I don't mind it you
know but whatever dude let's start this
freakin shit's [ __ ] go man yeah
welcome back from Cincinnati huh no I'm
gonna do this week right up the street
wait it's called the tough market tele
son I'm [ __ ] dare to get a day of mat
bro that's what I said they book it man
50 shades of brown what up on tour let's
do a 9/3 20/20 got big brown no ground
you got big brown little brown and
dangerous Brown
bro look I watch this I'm just saying
this I watches 911 videos we know who
did it okay
it's not like we think that's not a
conspiracy it's like we think the bugle
boys did it or whatever the Beagle boys
you know we know did it no big brown
little brown dangerous brown notorious
Brown you should go by that nickname oh
you remember that video game I'm
thinking of those aliens you man that
billion is RK called area 51 where you
rushed it and then shot the alien so
they want to remember that at a real
video game google that [ __ ] there yeah
video game area 51 it was identical to
what's going on right now you would raid
area 51 as a civilian Eric on the Google
took him nine minutes to find Barry
Larkin days still eight minutes faster
than chin yes five yeah really yeah did
they say art imitates life man that you
know you make something in an artistic
space then it comes alive that's crazy
what if the game's any good with a
rating right here when that's on place
it on top type in arcade game but that's
the same thing bro it's not bro okay it
came out in 1990 like I'm saying
nighttime before I create it for
PlayStation but yeah but then it gets
too serious yeah click on that lower art
what's the year on that there the truth
is in there
that's the wool ups and you raid the
warehouse you raid area 51 is a civilian
with guns Atari games 1995 holler at
your boy I went to a ladder in arcade
games man my mom dropped me off there
some say it was my baby
really job you have in your head you
Despres didn't play that game but they
pride ain't having your town oh dude we
had real ass games bro prairie dogs
being born if they had a dog if somebody
had a dog in heat you get out there and
people would lay money on how many bees
it was gonna have yeah that's cool man
oh dude my bub my buddy well my
brother's friend Larry won probably
almost $60 one time on a bichon had nine
babies in it yeah and that's I mean
nobody would bet that it's a miracle
really well think of how big a bichon is
dude kind of a Buster Douglas of dogs
Duffin underdog oh yeah oh wow how's
that good one Brendon
[Laughter]
but yeah you wouldn't even think you
could think fit non anything in a bichon
really and larry won that money over
there on mcgee street shot to Larry
doing bro we can still count knock knock
who's there an advertisement oh dude I
feel like you feel like asthma I've not
feel like a ball let me guess I know
what it is you've been feeling what mint
hyung Gration know what you're off
you're off I feel like a baller cuz I
basically have my own assistant that
delivers food whenever I need it
when I need wine at 4:00 p.m. I need
sushi in the middle of the night
I need a reckless breather at 8:00 a.m.
who are you no dude I feel me French I
feel like I'm Mark Cuban I just be
ordinary and him stuff I'm talking
postmates your personal food delivery
grocery delivery whatever you need all
year round man yeah it's crazy that some
people don't even know about postman
it's like they don't know that it's
available in our area they think oh
nobody will drive out a you know a half
a trunk full of chicken nuggets
right now wrong man get whatever you
want 24 hours a day 365 days a year
post mates we'll bring it within an hour
oh yeah download the app on your phone
and browse local restaurants businesses
and track your delivery in real time
yeah
yes and guess what dude I'm hooking
everybody post mates is given the king
of sting listeners $100 of free delivery
oh yeah don't want fries dude all right
sure oh I want a baguettes you know none
what else uh oh I wanna maybe a pudding
for dessert
John $100 a free delivery credit for
your first seven days to start your free
deliveries download the app and use the
code cats to zero one nine that's cats
2019 oh I want nuggets anything you need
anytime you need it post mates download
post mates and save with the code cats
2019 oh and ranch done time to buy few
more pants I'll handle this man look
nobody knows how to have hair issues or
a rectal dysfunction like yeah boy right
yeah
ah Jen gang limp limp and I'm thinking
hey Brendan what's a good name for a
medicine if you want something to be
around it's reliable and trustworthy and
you know Brendan he loves men so much he
said how about him hems it up and that's
it man
hims is a wellness brand for men because
66 percent of men and you know what men
are start to lose their hair by age 35
you know I want to get hairy I like I
want look like an Armenian so I start
taking it oh dude I want to look like
sugar ray puns Oh bra want to be able to
fight and have those follicles
I want that freakin Russian hair on my
shoulders oh dude don't like a girl my
armpits out there you don't I'm saying
take I wanna look like armpit
Longstocking what's up Scottie Pippen so
what I'm saying is if your hairline is
slowly starting to move backwards like
the French or if you have any bald spots
it's time to change it all up yeah but
what am I gonna do man I need a one-stop
shop for hair loss skin care and sexual
wellness for the bros oh look this will
handle it dude this thing will help your
hair this thing will help your wiener
this thing does it all hims hims was
created by a guy who knows men's health
conversations are easier online than in
person you're saying it's not awkward
anymore I have to send the doctor's
office and wait at the pharmacy forever
with my dick pills no you don't have to
do any of that for hems com connects you
to real doctors online dude all you do
is answer a few quick questions then
boom shows up at your house yeah not
doctors you've been going to like dr.
Doolittle or wherever you get your pills
there Phil yeah I'm talking real doctors
all right it can save you hours by doing
an online it's confidential it's
discreet answer a few questions a doctor
will review they determine if for hims
is right for you to hit him with that
deal hit him with that Harry deal my
listeners can get started with the hems
complete hair kit for just $5 today
right now while supplies last dude you
hit them with that Harry deal go to four
hems dot-com slash cats that's fo r hims
comp slash cat oh yeah for hims comm
slash cat
Hey yes cats are hairy and ukm b-24 hems
calm slash cats support the podcast
let's start with a new segment this week
boys will clown my hound
first one sit in this is dozer
this is dozer now what is clown my hound
Derek can you give us tell us what it is
because these are fan women in the dark
brother oh no problem is our fans
sitting in their animals all kinds of
animals that they own for you guys to
clown them and rip them up man well
apparently they the homeboy sent in a
goddamn Panther and this thing this
dozer now one thing I do know I don't
know a lot on this earth I know two
rivers we've been over that yeah still
one more than you here's the thing
though I dunno pups is that a cane corso
they didn't say what it is that ain't
that might be a pity cane corso I
believe is a Bellator fighter isn't it
it might be check if it isn't it
probably is gonna be next week there's a
lot of I feel like is that a dog you're
talking about
that's a dog yeah I can Corso Italian
king course of that but it looks like
two different dogs that's the same dog
on the left oh the same dog yeah I don't
know that's a [ __ ] pit bull visit
home bro first of all can we talk about
the dog on the right okay the same dog
the same dog oh sure it is
I don't believe it at all don't tell me
it is then and then say you don't
believe it well you just told me it is
why would you believe him that's a good
point
I'm speaking truth dude Cantus believe
people if they say somebody's insane
you're right keep jacking off to
snapchat you smell the truth you're
turning into CNN man [ __ ] in CNN
insane dude look into it that thing is
definitely anther actually on the left
wanna look into it bro what did he say
what happened to the pup on the road
yeah he's a year and a half he's rescued
from an abandoned house and the owner
accidentally broke his leg while playing
with him oh I don't know what that
that's like when you meet a girl she has
bruises on your [ __ ] foot on the
stairs yeah I was juggling with have
something real heavy year right that's
insane you got domestic abusers oh yeah
now let's but first of all how do we
know the one on the right I mean that
thing looks like it's hitchhikin is that
a tail is that a wiener it is a huge is
that a giant dick also where's the dice
the dog in Iraq where is that zoom LD
that ain't America baby is unless it's
area 51 could be area 51 bro this is
like it this looks like a UH like a
Heinz 57 in an area 51 you know yeah out
there right now that boys thick is that
a street you'll be rid behinds 57 what's
that that's ass all saying it will be
ketchup brown here but what's that
called of what is it called when they
mix a dog it's like a mixed uh-huh mutt
a mutt that ain't no mutt that thing
pure
broke that thing looks like a panther
dude that's an Iraqi Panther
it's an Iraqi Panther that they use out
there to defend their land it looks like
a lynx [ __ ] a safety cone dude animal
bro for those of you who are just
listening the animal has in one of its
entire legs all the way to the hip in a
orange cast broke bright orange cast oh
I know this is one of those off-white
pitbulls yeah this thing is mixed man
this thing from Seattle because well I
think with my rack bro ceiling of that
Brown [ __ ] dirt bro obviously Tigger
has been [ __ ] outside of his animal
both in two months this thing is gonna
be like oh can we do a tiger voice you
kinda look like Tigger a little will you
do it there I don't memorize it I forget
Tigger yeah and everybody the first one
a try Tigger is always so brave well
what no that's not it Yegor
so one play taker and then let's see
how's the best ticket
[Music]
fast forward to that goddamn stupid
tiger don't climb trees come on let's go
let's go that's pretty good that's how
the heifer come on let's go yeah get to
his catchphrase only have a damn
catchphrase no one can have a
catchphrase that's good Oh
Tigger's an old man that's it where's my
tail oh my god that's your guy yeah the
depressed one yeah
dude if we're characters I'm Tigger
you're that stupid donkey I me or but he
or I'll say this badass dude hammers his
tail into his [ __ ] ass every day do
the real mail yeah he does here's the
thing about the DJ I polish he dude he's
so depressed medication
yeah but they sometimes they don't show
him where he's on vacation and he's
having a [ __ ] blast that makes sense
I just like how this dog on the left
that ain't don't don't say this pretty
sure doggy on the left the thing on the
right to legal first of all the one on
the left
uh what is it [ __ ] it looks like it
got into an argument at a stereo shop or
something why doesn't have that finger
on its face they would an idiot it keeps
biting this cast off apparently oh
really so they give him a cone of shame
that ain't even the same dog I don't get
this [ __ ] on my face any other facts on
this thing dude cone in the front cone
in the back this either either as a
safety cone or its limb or it has a what
is that a bike car yeah pick one dude
either wear the cone you really got down
this thing it's doing research for
definitely for Sam Tripoli in Eddie
Bravo
looks like trying to get a frequency on
the left our seventh Safety Hunter right
here this thing looks like it's trying
to [ __ ] pick up AM radio well let's at
once I just signed the petition at
[ __ ] rush area 51 on the left yeah man
this thing with that it looks like the
Horace Grant of animals
nice to keep its act together but yeah
man
obviously the [ __ ] there's no way
this little bot out here on the right in
the [ __ ] gargoyle on the right is the
same as that [ __ ] the cone baby on
the level where'd they get the cast
worked on hey but also do better
honey dunk it's too bad around which the
same pub bro this thing so this thing is
hurt but still trying to [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying when you getting that
beautiful ass orange cast he'll still
protect the land house even gonna bother
at the land bro you know many other
animals are gonna be able to see him
with that do right orange cast that's a
front though you think you're gonna make
it on there they break sound rips your
dick oh I could see that so it's like a
bait in a a bait and switch yeah I say
that what else we got D Wow what's the
animal's name did it have a name dozer I
don't think the biggest gay dude at a
bad now what do you know about all that
Brendon
now bathhouses no guys named dozer dude
yeah that's a great name here you have
three in your [ __ ] phone up next guys
we got ad lists this is Atlas oh wow
okay what's going on with that boy he's
three days waiting for nobody look like
he's going through some sad [ __ ] it
looks like you just got dumped Lindsay's
[ __ ] heart Brian Tyler fair lad boy
that's not a
smoking in the boys room dude what
happened t-pain e-pass away from pain
huh
the pain got too much it was just it was
just it was just pain at the end he lost
the t it just turned into pain ah dude
this is the jab again we're so [ __ ]
urban no I'm [ __ ] racial look at you
bro welcome to 50 shades of brown again
dude we gotta buy some guns bro what
that real [ __ ] wrestle ah I got a
little bit of sand in the chamber you
know a little turban in the convoy this
dogs been through a lot huh yeah hey
that dogs seen some [ __ ] he's seen
everything look so you seen all the
members in the house get murdered look
at it right now it's not doing well man
well no [ __ ] eg has a thing of his a
which appears to be at least be a
32-ounce in a bag you know and look at
me by the door obviously got locked out
or left or someone doesn't even allow no
people are murdered inside he's the only
one that survived no look at me yeah
look at his eyes dude his eyes are so
like dear God
he needs Jesus in his life yeah walking
I could agree he could use a [ __ ] hit
of the J bruh Otero di like though that
wet nose I love a wet nose on apartment
bro that's gin on his nose okay his nose
is probably about 35 proof okay together
35 yeah dude why would who was the owner
of Scooby Doo
whens imma [ __ ] her high all the time
Maggie shaggy OH
Shaggy's going through some just good
dude how do you not get casted as the
live action shaggy boy
Long's row you and I have done nothing
voices they're all the same
Teager and scooby sound exactly the same
shout out to this dog that seen some
murder and its life what else we got
here's an ad from the king in the state
Mac Weldon is that your buddy yeah you
ranting raving about Mac weld and I'm
like dude I've got a mop did a new
brother I've got him in my pants right
now bro
uh-huh yeah dude and it's not like one
of them little sexual deals it's a Mac
Weldon it's basically like somebody just
did a lot of like welding with cloth
around your Mac you feel me it's
Underpants
it's underwear and socks it's men's
drawers dude it's also athletic they
have some athletic pants but the thing
about sweats
yes sweat pants word if you sweat in
them dude not if you just walk around
like a little Muppet like you yeah you
have some ax in them are you a punk to
me they're sweat pants to you they're
snack slacks what I'm talking about is
that Mac Weldon Underpants that I'm
wearing right now oh they look good
brother looks like premium stuff Oh Mac
well demand these guys they came correct
tell me what some about Matt what's Mack
doing Oh max welding good cloth around
you junk bro Mack up Mack Weldon is
better than whatever you're wearing
right now so whatever you're wearing
right now like in your pants like
another man's saliva this Trump's that
dude I'm wearing nothing oh yes I need
that Mac attack
dude what I'm saying is Mac Walton
believes in smart design premium fabrics
and simple shopping whoo they make socks
shirts undershirts hoodie sweatpants and
jay-z pants for tail yeah you just go
online my joke you go on behind you uh
and you just pick out what you want and
it comes to you so easy my look man that
right now I got three pairs of unders
from them and I'm really absolutely dig
you know yeah you look happy man sell it
to Mac you look like a Mac Daddy there
you want to be a Mac Daddy
get 20% off your first order visit Mac
welding dot-com enter promo code tats
and look some of our listeners are
similar tuberin and not that greatest
spellers it's M ACK wel do win
come and enter promo code k 80s
yeah math daddy yeah you're gonna love
it man your crops will feel good your
thighs breath III bruh
daddy's feeling crispy oh yeah someone's
got to pay for Brennan's coffee habit
yo deal mm-hmm your website bro actually
didn't need a website I'm thinking about
maybe redoing my website for for this
past weekend and even just for
everything for everything I think we
should maybe I'm freaking this thing we
need a brief amp everything you need
these wicks bro wicks is a free platform
that allows you to build a highly
customization professional robust lusty
website dude yeah I want something fancy
on my website I want like a picture
videos maybe yeah pretty easy font all
types of neat stuff images that I that
I've taken that I can put on there yeah
standard website stuff sounds like you
need some professional and again Rome
bust that gives you a total creative
freedom it's so good man go to Wix baby
wakes it up see it looks like a candle
like Wyck s wi x go to Wix WI XCOM slash
go slash cats to start your own Wix
website for free or upgrade to a yearly
premium plan and get 20% off by using
promo code cats 20 that's Wix WI x-com
slash go slash cats to start your own
Wix website for free oh yeah and they
got all kind of stuff they have over 120
million registered users they offer Wix
code which allows you to extend the
functionality of your Wix website using
advanced functionality and code it's so
dang easy it's free it's reliable
hosting it's really that one shop stop
and if you get amazing results man
amazing results go to wix.com slash go
slash cats to start your own Wix website
for free or upgrade to yearly premium
plan you get 20% off by using the promo
code cats 20k 80s to zero
trying to keep lights on all right
it makes a little debate club gang bring
it bro bring that hitter tip for them
pounds huh
hands down baby hound down first we got
Rob from England Rob today Rob this is
debate and I'll see you guys September
over here in Manchester and London and
Glasgow Scotland is free how's it going
feel and Brendan is Rob here from
England just coming up for a debate club
question for you guys the new John wick
films just come out here recently it
looks pretty good looking forward to
seeing it it has got me thinking who he
wins in a fight John wick or John
McClain from die hard he you pick Gang
Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz gangster and gang
haven't seen die hard in the heart
circuit what was his thing what was his
saying in die hard yippee-kay-yay
yippee-kay-yay [ __ ] and he had a
wife beater on and he's just barefoot
and jeans the entirety was Bruce Willis
though true the other got John wick is
who Keanu
Keanu Reeves who's a baller but here's
the thing about above all or do
Superbowl here's where maybe at Dave and
Buster's dude dude he doesn't miss the
matrix
Keanu to facial expressions reads
killing what Stewart he's play the same
guy in every movie Keanu Reeves always
looks like he's looking at a menu and I
wasn't decided what he wants yet okay
Bruce Willis is a [ __ ] Savage bro
well he did he did hook up with Demi
Moore dude he hooked up with Demi Moore
he hooked up with Ashton Kutcher she
hooked up with he died already died
harder he came back Danny Glover
then he pulp and fiction yeah but we
think of all that he did god I would say
fridges Wooster mr. Reeves is bigger
though the matrix okay matrix iír wick
he kills
70,000 people cuz his dog died yeah well
sounds like is issues to me okay might
well but here's the thing John wick I
feel like he's being pushed onto people
Bruce Willis was a legend
diehard was a legend matrix I'll give
you man I don't know from coming up with
this Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure
okay that's fine where's Ted at let's
look up Ted what's he up to dad died
did he really no they did they were like
hey we're gonna do we're gonna revamp
the series and you like it bubbling
ready please don't though
but please don't Ted Theodore Logan look
like Ted went swimming in a [ __ ] pool
of meth what's his name the other guy's
name is a Alex winter ooh if you
remember he was also in come on The Lost
Boys he was a vampire
oh wow murdered Lost Boys great movie
very good movie oh there he is right now
it's winter so first of all say this man
he left his boy by the side dude so he
obviously
Kian who hadn't brought Alex along with
him which Alex in last what was his last
film can look at as I am dealing Texan
adventure he still might be killing it
there was just a lot of documentaries oh
man maybe he's like he's making
documentaries now yeah what's the last
movie he did though was quantum is
calling CoV quantum is calling TV movie
so Keanu left his boy behind now Danny
Glover still doing big [ __ ] dude what up
white bring it Danny Glover into this
but cuz go Bruce Willis's boy what's
Danny Glover do it no good y'all stink
at least a weapon [ __ ] god damn it
Bruce Willis [ __ ] GI Jane bro think
about that
well she had a shaven head that right
now I'm thinking about what he did
shields a dude KITT who was one of his
friends from an early movie did he bring
his friends along with no one he was
always riding solo
he had that dumbass girlfriend pulp
fiction I want the blueberries if you
remember Mel Gibson's a [ __ ] G bro aim
small miss small yeah it's great
Bruce Willis Patriot one of the 60 best
movies ever made dude mr. Reeves
highlight your boy
88% of people went with wick yeah but of
course whatever man Blazing Saddles the
Patriots a league of their own what else
is good gigantic Friday the first one
the other ones [ __ ] [ __ ]
no I'm saying two years later y'all
still sitting around the neighborhood
bro
you know what I'm saying it's time to
[ __ ] get a job bro and what's the
lather movie
oh no not avatar dude beautiful mind
what else we got Derek up next we have
Michael Fisher from Toronto this is
still debate international fans huh yeah
a lot of international this week wow
look out boys hold on
I love how Brendan says international
like he's [ __ ] selling some of the
unique secret you know a lot of
international fans I'm gonna say Toronto
and then [ __ ] before is England I'm
sorry man I'm being kind of rude
no you there's guys in the back I think
Mel Gibson's Danny Glover's might be
boys Mike Fisher from Toronto Canada I'm
a huge fan Theo Rendon serious question
for you guys when you're on the [ __ ]
and you finish your business do you
stand up to wipe or do you lean to wipe
I myself like to stand gang gang white
boy okay wipe it wipe it
no no white people are really just that
this a turn a [ __ ] I was talking about
them those run through the six with it
with a shitty but you think it's Riley
think Greg you're wrong I think you guys
like this with maple syrup bro this guy
looks just like Drake first of all let's
be realistic you need new glasses dude
really crazy directly drinks pretty
white bro okay yeah I guess makes way
more white and black dude brother the
toughest thing ever happened to him is
he borrowed his uncle's car and he
barely got it back to him
well his mom's white right and his dad's
black mom's Georgia yeah he said is that
he's like Derrick would you consider
Derrick white or black Oh Derrick is
definitely he's a real black adaptil
black adaptil Barry has a real
Derrick has some ethnicity and I'm from
Memphis right okay ready black also
Drake from well he grew up in like born
in Toronto they grew up in Memphis they
went back to Toronto I know yes
we grew up in Memphis hold on oh wow say
meow no Drake comes up to me a lot a lot
whiter to me I don't know what do you
guys think let's hit the Colts corner
what do we even know Brendon look we
don't know anything about black people I
mean yeah you keep denying that you're a
big Mexican guy to pee oh my tourist
called 50 shades Browns to be fair I
don't think he knows what he is either
he's going through a Jamaican phase
right now
easy yeah yeah that's why how was any
[ __ ] Rihanna true berry true true I'd
start speaking Jamaican - I mean yeah
but wiping the butts what do you guys
think Scott yeah uh oh yeah mr. Fisher
thanks for reaching out man you seem
like a good guy
and this guy's from Toronto he's run
through the six bro
I'm about to put some tour dates up four
on him and I got to get up there me too
man we should go to Montreal and do a
show together I agree
that'd be fun I'd be cool huh I'd be
cool you been to Montreal
uh just for that the jib only I'm not
doing I suppose no they rake you yes
we'll go up to ourselves yeah I'd love
to get a much hottest wonder if people
will come out of Montreal
you know Toronto is great Toronto every
I've never done shows a Montreal though
I want to go up there man I'll look
don't go up there in the winter clothes
place I've ever been
I'll go in the winter dude [ __ ] that I
ain't doing it I'm not afraid of that
stuff dude season six a game of Thrones
right now dude sighing no hope the white
wall bro huh the white wall yeah don't
tell me don't tell me if you don't feel
in July you don't finish it by August
I'm gonna spoil the entire thing what
month is it right now when July you have
you have 45 days okay all right fair
enough you have a unique calendar mr.
Fisher here's what I say dude wipe your
butt bro I don't care how you do it I
don't care if you do is sitting down
standing up I don't care if you jump
right in the shower that's next to you
hit him but day you're in Toronto bro
yeah if that water fountains shoot your
[ __ ] or get a Bedok broom and get
that dog from the first pick with that
Kohner on his face
he looks like he's ready to freaking
wash some but you know definitely you do
he ain't go nowhere that limp leg
either way man doesn't hey does it
matter don't you get it done bro you're
gonna get some pink are you gonna get
some down time in your up time you know
what I'm sayin so you can end up in
Pittsburgh that's what I'm sayin is take
care of your butt if you're emailing two
guys on the internet to find out what
you got to do what you behold Craigslist
bro bro looking for a glory hole come on
bro you're an apple man - old be askin
is this yeah my shout-out mr. Fisher
drinking that Bush light is that a
Canadian beer is Bush Canadian no
Milwaukee
it sure is bro so it looks like you're
sipping across the border bro drink
something local you got all that clean
beer up they don't they a traitor and
clean your household yeah bro and fill
you fill your frickin front hole with a
Molson daddy stay woke brother reach and
thank you for sending that in mr. fishy
that's fine thank you 71% of people lien
city should be drinking lean have you
ever tried lean huh have you ever tried
that a little before bed is it nice want
some so bad dude super thirsty for lame
Bob I'm gonna cue City like too much oh
yeah I get lean and hit the stage you
got to you guys should do a behind the
scenes Brendon does lean video yeah I'm
just coming out tattoos on my face
looking like a little Wayne
well tell his son to get a um like an
ak-47 that also does videography and
that way you could fill my burning does
leave behind the scenes
50 shades of brown behind the lead real
documentary rage wrong yeah name Lina
big brown gets lean yeah I got my mouth
waters when I talk about lean though
really yeah a little sprite a little
scissor oh yeah a little shop Oh bro put
on some David Banner son it changed your
life son Oh
David Banner is a legend bro yes he
passed away right no he didn't do
everyone died he's heavy on Instagram
do you if you're gonna do lean though
it's Paul Wall right in Houston yeah
don't you know him
Paul wall yeah peoples champ did I met
him one time at a urinal honestly dude
oh yeah he was in there and I was in
there and I knew was him and why hadn't
I told him I knew it was him that was it
he had that girl in uh-oh I'm the healer
how do you think he stays on that is he
still rocking the grill like riding
around with like spinners and [ __ ] he
still makes girls yeah he's a legend oh
he's got a lot of producing right oh
yeah big time especially Behrman South
Texas he's a silent killer he's like
emphysema dog he's [ __ ] he's doing it
behind the scenes maybe like just light
yeah you don't know it's too late and
they sing you know Paul's a billionaire
yeah give me some lean know what else
you got up next new segment boys little
punk my uncle its Punk's or monks I said
a flop my out it's Punk my listen in
there uncle's this time to rip him up
and let me get clear here Derek in the
urban community punk has like a
different meaning to it yeah I mean what
does it mean could mean someone of a gay
or descent no punk-ass old who likes the
way the dictation yeah interesting a
pumpkin you know in our culture don't
white let's be real in our culture okay
chill out on the whole I think so
hey come on so in our culture it's kind
of like like a [ __ ] if you're a punk
yeah punk [ __ ] that's what we did is
wrong [ __ ] is listening who just want
to be one we should all be a punk or a
[ __ ] I'd rather be kind of a little bit
of a punk ass me too public any things
to happen yeah and use a punk to like
fireworks that's the thing where I'm
from a punk is something they used to
like fireworks that little thing you
know oh yeah you like the UH that little
stick it's like almost an incense stick
but you know scent in it yeah and my
Patton like the fireworks
oh-ho and you pour you like you to smell
something burning bright it's only rich
people that like oh let's put cinnamon
in it let's make this lavender
how about we just smell the fire that's
the best thing about being poor just
burning [ __ ] in your yard Brian nobody
calls the cops three rich people that's
a fire people it's just hey dog let's
burn this
let's burn this [ __ ] yeah yeah I prefer
Punk though let's get into it though
Punk could be a gay person yeah yeah
yeah I don't know still younger people
use now that's definitely older black
baby yeah I hear it sometimes in
Mississippi when I was growing up people
I didn't know that this is you learned
something with you guys oh yeah they say
Big Mike a pump he over there about a
juke joint and he getting wild with
those fellas that's what I would hear oh
wow a nice to do yard work with Big Mike
didn't he'd never hit on me bro
and he'd we get on the ride and lawn
mower and actually he would take his
shirt off and let me [ __ ] ride on his
back I don't know what I was like Big
Mike rode the lawn mower while you rode
his back well I wasn't old enough to
drive it but I was [ __ ] ride on his
back like I'd be fun when you're young
Oh like an LL Bean browse on his back
it's like a feeling book holder bro like
a camel back yeah and he would just sip
water out of me I was just spit water in
his mouth every now just sip the sweat
when he was Thursday if you know camel
back there that's funny I forgot about
him man was a big sweat bro yeah we used
to work together but he had the big mic
and he was homosexual and he passed away
actually from from the AIDS I don't know
what happened dude I think I think he
got tired of being alive - he worked a
lot and it's a lot it's a lot but he had
the biggest afro I've ever seen him we
should get on that ridin lawnmower bruh
and we cut in about 20 acres you know
riding lawnmower take us no joke a week
bro would you get paid so we'd be out
there yeah we got paid I just did it for
the companionship night this ain't like
now you're making us sound like a real
early herb rural episode of robbing big
sounds like a southern robbing being on
but you didn't get paid but it was cool
that sounds like Driving Miss Daisy he
was driving me he was driving mister
little dumbass that's driving the puppy
yeah driving
dumbass a real Punk off who well let me
see this punk-ass uncle first this is
Troy this is Uncle Troy Troy a punk
painted this is Troy in his wife Tami
[Music]
nothing better than white people dancing
look at that drama she's got two
[Music]
know they're on a cruise no that is in
their house man
they're just in the house getting
crunked troy loves golf listens to drake
mm-hmm oh yeah and then he's just like
drake basically yeah yes Drake Drake is
obviously the defense rests on how white
race hey this guy's way too happy for me
there's nothing ever gone wrong in his
life you don't dance the two legit in
2019 without just life being good like
that
leave play that again for me I've never
danced this happy in my life the leg
lift was gives it away oh yeah dude this
guy's never gotten a parking ticket bro
you have a lot of very similar moves
Latroy talk about white boots bro yeah
we do
this guy's balling up that right now
this guy's living life it's harvest he's
out there with his wife she gots a
little biscuit or something in her hand
a Ponzi scheme
going on he's too happy you know and you
just she's encountered a shitload of
money and they get caught that's the
vibe I get it he definitely could be you
know
Sonique in an extra callaway club in his
bag he uh he dances a little too good
for a man that's 100 percent straight I
think I agree there's a little sugar in
his tank if you catch my drift
but I like the way his legs and arms are
exactly the same type of appendage it
seems like if you look at his leg arm
combo it's it's almost it's like a
mirror image of one another and so that
allows you a certain you know when you
dance it's just like your body's just
doing one fluid motion I'd assume there
may be Florida I'd also assume that this
isn't the first time they've put on some
MC to the hammer and danced like this
cuz they're in sequence yeah with the
leg lifts the short jeans everything
they're having fun this is 4th of July
this when their kids see him and be like
oh mom and dad are in love they're
having a good time they're still doing
the damn thing yeah shoutout to them T
Roy shut out the T Roy and Tammy T
squared
oh yeah will you MC Hammer fan or
Vanilla Ice you had to pick one
be a fan of both remember they hated
each other they did oh yeah how well
they're they're just the enemies you
know why because they're both killing
the charts and they both had baggy pants
on just zoom but pants i setting cmcm on
airplane one time next to who next to
hammer he used to be my manager
did he really Wow he was the nicest
super nice yeah
really neat man actually I was smart man
really smart guy yeah I was shocked at
how yes just how much more than just a
musician but then it also kind of made
sense it was like oh he kind of had
these hits they were you know he I mean
he it's a bad business so apparently
though he just loved too many people it
seemed like he was paying everybody
here's a squad of 150 if you even met
you he'd give you a job he met you just
gave you a hundred grand I did nothing
but say heizak I know it's your honor
basically the first Bernie Sanders
really was want to just get rid of
everyone's death he was socialism do it
so he's trying to do yeah and look it
didn't pan out but no a deep here's the
thing we talk to him he's like I was
like damn you were broke cuz we got
close I was it game your bro Chios I was
MC Hammer broke I was still living in a
mansion I still driving Ferraris like
you I was empty hammer broke I'm not
like broke like everyone says he's also
the first and one of the first investors
in Facebook hmm homeboys he was ballin
he was going to some big [ __ ] still
ballin with rich people whenever I met
him he was going to a comic but he was
nice as could be man he was like as
humble and normal of the probably he's
not nice it has some great stories oh
yeah dude he told me a story about so
funny he said that man I forgot about
the best road walk this right when
Prince had died so he said that one time
he was on tough times and he needed to
shoot a video and they didn't have a
place or something
Prince was on tough times one was on
tough times right Prince and they the
other one had him said you can come and
shoot it at my place and next thing you
know like 35 people showed up and stayed
at the other person's house for like
three weeks
you shot a rad video Wow little factory
I was in MC Hammer music video were you
really yep
is it true look over the video
believable that everybody's about to
lose it I mean I'm an infernal uber
I'm in it for a hot second which one I'm
not in the back dancing I thought I'd be
in it dancing but I'm clearly not oh
dude you're a hot SEC what no song with
ah yeah you definitely [ __ ] remember how
are you thinking about it dude
well don't know which MC crunch of
videos dude what I think it's gonna run
run run MC Hammer run oh my god dude you
couldn't get any [ __ ] weirder bro
were you an MC Hammer video Oh bro you
met him in a bathroom stall
I was it because I'm you met him and
Paul wall in a bathroom stall listen
water I got questions bro I get some
questions
I do well you don't have any answers you
know these people in the stalls you got
questions better run that's me that's
their jay-z dis video dude I mean this
is so stupid I'm in for like a second of
video not like dancin yeah I'm a video
vixen who cares bro it's obvious [ __ ]
had the weirdest career of anyone ever
we've ever met what are you in next
Armus Todd how much we're gonna get
Brendon then you chasing a couple black
guys in the woods this looks illegal
you're not giving out a show d okay yeah
why are you right there
oh that's Kat will you write that's MC
Hammer that's me in the back by Sargon
will you stop so we can all feel what
it's like to realize you were in this
video what do you think what are you
stepping on it bro let's go to the
culture corner man I don't know how to
feel right now dude this is crazy
and what do you mean by crazy I would
like to know a little bit more about
this like cool you've done enough we've
seen the video there's you behind Katt
Williams
it's a really yes well this is when he
was smoking Katt Williams at the time
because he is very Katt Williams in this
picture all right Derrick 1qy interview
your your buddy here I think this is the
black of [ __ ] you've ever done give it
our bug don't yeah thanks man I don't
know how to feel about this I have
conflicting feelings thank you it makes
sense I mean I have no words thank you
thank you
oh I'm sorry who was a good MC Hammer
video nobody all right yeah I was in a
bad baby music video you freaking piece
of yeah that's right you played a
pedophile bro listen no I made a curious
adult you paid you played a pedophile
listen bad baby ain't [ __ ] a bit MCM
she's the MC Hammer of today you know
dance
MC Hammer to get famous off [ __ ] dr.
Phil catch me outside it's MC Hammer you
[ __ ] bro dude you're the one who's
standing behind him like you're trying
to sell them at an auction bro this is a
sadist piece of videography I've ever
seen dude oh you're not condone this
kind of [ __ ] I want to say that but you
do that bad baby video where you're a
pedophile the curious adult Brendon okay
who was misled by the [ __ ] hey my
society let's do this not the fans vote
what's cooler MC Hammer video or a bad
Barbie or where the [ __ ] you up cat
there's a great how take that has never
been released of their like say whatever
you want to bad baby right now right
we're gonna do this and I was like you
crazy [ __ ] I love it I just think it's
too like it's too spot-on
oh yeah that's right he just needs to on
the knows that you know and
like hey bro no you tell us the way well
we can't use that deal
we definitely why because yeah we really
should put that up though unless you may
put that up you definitely should that's
hilarious
well what was the boy who was given X we
got one more uncle this is a you sit in
a bunch of his uncle's this is Gabriel
Saavedra and his family okay now here's
the thing boys
damn the new cast of Jersey Shore looks
fun two of these uncles are gay oh yeah
oh they wants to pick the gay so yeah
which one you think oh hell yeah it's
the punk on a couple questions before we
start
yeah Brennan's all hyped up to pick gay
yeah I got all their names I got I mean
you know who is gay I know who yes okay
this cat no okay let's get let's get
some pics across the board okay I'll
just no yeah um let me sniff out the
punk let's say the bald one want me to
say all their names in the mom on the
left this is his mom all right guys mama
farlows mom then right here we got uncle
Joey the second one in it gives left to
right uncle Joey second one in then we
got Uncle Tony
Joey such choice this is grandma okay
and then I can Sandra next to Grandma
then we got uncle Augie Oh Auggie will
lick your [ __ ] uncle Christian uncle
Christians next to Auggie this is
Christian dude good chance they sued
Christian show up to the same stop the
omec Paul Wally
dude I'm going with Oggy the bald one
for sure and then I think homeboy second
in with the with the hookah
the hookah shells in the back there you
go do Joey okay I got Joey and then the
Baldwin with the sleeve
I like your boy [ __ ] Tony with that
smoke guy he's wearing that smoke I got
which ones that
terney the far right yeah Tony is
oh no Paul's on the fall right Paul is
the one who put a couple ricotta you
know a couple of uh a couple of
manicotti in front of you in and sneak
around your booty while you while you
snack that's you know he's obviously a
chef dude look at me what happened this
what ethnicity are they I'm pretty sure
they're all I mean the last name Savita
Saavedra so sa Algerian maybe they don't
look - they don't look a Latino though
they're not Mexican no no no but they
got some flavor so just give me the -
you think are punks still I mean I would
like to call them gay friends first of
all well the same is called punk my own
so just punks okay and they're literally
over pump my own tell me what you won
like sweet and low in their iced tea oh
I'll tell you what uh I mean the one
guy's been in prison the guy with the
full arm tattoo all the way down to the
wrist that's why I think he's down but
the one on the left he has arm on the
woman that's his wife obviously so you
got to be careful
the honest is they're holding the young
son I'm going with Tony number two right
here with the checkered shirt yeah I'm
going to check her sure Tony bro he
likes he brought that checkered shirt so
he's ready to throw a picnic on his back
you feel me dude and he's ready to
picnic and heaven
and then I'm going my boy Hardy Paulie
on the right Brian put that bolognaise
in front of Dumbo a wife-beater bandit
yeah better hell on the right Brendan a
big guy on the right all this chain
double the biggest dude on yeah yeah
this uh yeah don't write who's right
probably my sorry sorry am i right who's
right
oh because you said don't you didn't
guess don't can't you want to get cat
sure
I think it's Christian and the do react
with Guy Fieri looking one yes would
just point me which one I don't know
they're [ __ ] their names oh yeah I
don't remember the entire family on 80
names Christian oh yeah what else
Christian on there huh
which one's Christian Christian is the
one with no sleeves the wife beater yeah
yep give it up dude alright you guys
want to know yeah do not touch me
anymore but keep touching me okay uncle
Joey in the back with the hookah shells
Wow with the glasses he's won it well
he's gay and then gameful Christian with
the sleeves without the sleeve yeah with
the paint with the tank top wow you
can't you don't even know anymore dude
the tank top
yeah it's Christian I thought he's a
Marine yeah yeah no no he could be I
don't know don't tell it's crazy
please tell ya what is I can't tell I'd
the one up for the hookah chefs come on
tell us that's so easy but the one there
are flexing on us with the good body and
the wife beater here's what I use out to
play maybe pickup game maybe throw the
ball around oh yes I don't want to share
some kool-aid and get busy in the back
you feel me
well maybe he doesn't want sex Bernie
maybe just wants to meet somebody who
spent some time with someone see that's
how you cut in them stalls the paul wall
we should have a gay military I think
first of all it's completely separately
let him fight Barcelona all the time to
just party at the club's
they would love it it's not a bad idea
dude they get to Ibiza travels around
the world at parties yeah the [ __ ] the
town yeah you know what they're called
Spartans do that's what they used
do whatever it is believe in three out
of you
perhaps your mom let's keep a little
yeah all right boys we got one
relationship advice for me we're really
helping the nation with this stuff you
do yeah I remember the last dude who was
smoking weed with his wife I came we
gave them just dimes what is this
relationship with us let's get cat why
don't you help us house start off here
what is it don't play the video sorry
well I just want a female perspective
I'm tired of listening to this a real
female perspective I'm time to listen to
this big [ __ ] over here Punk it's his
relationship advice from snapchat yeah
well I cut it I already eliminated it
from my phone all right boys up first we
got Lindsay Miller this is Lindsay
Miller asking for some more
relationships so far this decayed a girl
got that lens crown guys this is Lindsay
out of Illinois I had a relationship
question for you I've been dating this
guy for about six years now and we just
separated about a week and a half ago
long story short he has issues with
financial stability which I take very
seriously he's personally with a bad
attitude I'm not the friendliest person
in the world but we do love each other
dearly we believe that we're soul mates
we don't want to be with anybody else
but we just can't seem to get along in
the middle on things he's broke in a bad
mood all the time because we do love
each other so much that we should just
let it be that and be together or if
each of our issues we should take
seriously and maybe soul mates just
because we're so much doesn't mean that
we're meant to be together
you know sometimes stuff doesn't work
out so I want to know your opinion on it
and thanks for listening Gang Gang
buzzbuzz buzzbuzz girl like the purple
nail polish I love Illinois man one of
my favorite places in the whole world
I like Illinois Australia I think yeah
you might want to just take some time
apart and figure out maybe what's going
on on your own in I think a little time
apart could give you probably some
perspective you know it's not for myself
I find when I'm in a relationship I'm in
a
proximity with someone sometimes I get
so I can't even see what's going on cuz
I'm just in there it's like I don't know
what's going on the box yeah it's a
camera from said a damn form said it if
I'm upset at me like I don't really know
where my issues are so I think taking
some time apart to probably be good and
look these days if you have somebody
that's a best friend like you could make
a relationship out of that like not
being a cheap ass box here's what's
going on with her sounds like dipping in
for six years homeboys never found a job
so she's frustrated with it mmm you tell
me homeboy hasn't found a job in six
years maybe just lazy maybe that's why
you're frustrated yeah maybe he's a punk
well I mean yeah one of yo you can't be
the only breadwinner cuz you're gonna
probably end up having some resentments
against him or maybe we wants to be a
sugar baby I mean some people will be
sure your babies how many of y'all think
it's just women won't be sugar babies
dudes like to be sugar baby punk oh yeah
that's true they got them baby sugar
baby punk so maybe if you could start a
small business give him a job dude start
driving uber yeah has he tried bad well
there's probably some opportunity out
there for him but yeah if you're angry
obviously if you're upset something
either you're upset at him or something
just not making you happy
but I'd figure out what that is
especially your soul mates money doesn't
break up soul mates you know I'm saying
well she says that they still want to be
soul mates Brendan yeah but looks like
you're looking for an expensive soul
mate you feel me
well I mean you can't have a soul mate
that's just eaten all the snacks and
doing all of the cheese slices by
themselves and you don't have anything
left yeah you have to split up them
dunkaroos baby yeah you need a snack
mate you need somebody to contribute to
a snack pool yep get them gushers get
the fruit by the foot yeah bye good luck
maybe just take a little bit of space
and figure it out
step outside the box you have it's a
cheap-ass box but you got to accept him
too if he doesn't want to get a job and
you're still and you're gonna be with
him then don't hold it against him every
day that he doesn't have a job if he
wants to be lazy Larry LEM do his thing
you signed up for it right yeah you just
have to like at some point it's not fair
for you to be like you don't have a job
every day then you're just having him
stay around so you could be be kind of
rude maybe - yeah if you come home from
your 9:00 to 5:00 and he's making forts
every day you're playing [ __ ] caller
be cool that's what you signed up for
she's teddy grahams
dude that sounds like the life Lazard
this guy's awesome be cool lady yeah
[ __ ] cool that's you got well let's
go do that let's go over to the let's
get order an actual female Brendan not
this you know an actual female
I mean after six years I think she's
just mad that he isn't contributing I
think he doesn't have a job or he
doesn't have a higher paying job he's
lazy Larry exactly but after six years
you gotta know whether you want to be
with that for for the next like 20 30
years or if you need to find someone
else being a soul mate is great but then
the day you're gonna resent them if they
don't pull their share but what to tell
you about if your soul mates lazy as
[ __ ]
what's it say if you're soul mates oscar
the grouch but also you can't just be
mean to him every day maybe does she get
off on that because some girl i feel
like some people a [ __ ] but some people
do like to have like a punching bag to
come home to regardless of what he's
trying to do cuz i mean maybe he's
trying his very best she's not who she's
smoking cigarettes playing call of duty
late at night yeah well maybe I'd open
up snapchat looking at booty hauls maybe
that's why she's an [ __ ]
yeah well maybe they still live in an
apartment okay and they don't live in a
fancy house that as a pool and extra
sinks well maybe they should get their
[ __ ] together cuz they can yeah maybe
they can't you delinquent
you a punk Wow mean guy
well well she's quit being mean can we
go through the Coast applications again
for a nice person see if anybody put
that on their application not this DV
and who said he went to college nobody's
ever heard of it Manchester State
wouldn't the [ __ ] was that man what
Jesus Christ man what it sounds like you
and her should get together oh okay
get a job you bandwagon fan is not a job
dude
your fan doesn't pay the bills yeah
they're built for to need [ __ ] Teddy
Grahams every afternoon but what's that
your Zion William
in Jersey just came in oh wow and it's
tight - yep at yours it's a medium ha
all right let's get to the end of this
dude I can't stay I can't deal with him
anymore boys we got one King understand
then we'll wrap it up this is from Moses
from Las Vegas this is Moses from Moses
gang gang bro it hold on a second does
he know us up
stay out of lb bleh let's go daddy huh
hey Brendan hey Theo does Moses coming
at you from pump the meth capital of
Nevada King interesting for you brothels
no Bo I'll see you in Vegas and August
gangbang bus bus boy okay gang bang bus
that's in brothels I have no problem the
brothel bro really
no bye would you how's it any different
than getting a massage you're massaging
my [ __ ] you know I'm saying it's just a
part of skin and skin yeah it's all good
if a girl wants to make a good living
like that it's all good oh I don't think
there's anything wrong with that I don't
like a lot of brothels don't feel as
disinfected to me as other establishment
well they don't have an outside this
building yeah it's usually like a see if
you go inside of a bank I feel like it's
like a teller the pans are chained up
you need a little more professional yeah
yeah I want that higher end I guess that
bra fell go to the bunny ranch baby yeah
that's where Lamar Odom spent all his
money oh yeah
that's crazy man they almost killed him
over there he's hopped up on that
cocaine to cocaine just too much dick
sucked in bro on the last place I want
to be doing cocaine is out in the desert
and there's high temps bro I'm more but
maybe outside of Lansing Michigan I'll
do some cocaine you know and drink that
brown water 50 shades of brown you've
seen their water yes dude I was hanging
out with daddy a damn long neck this
weekend bro oh you wish from there yeah
and that's where it was he's from
Michigan yeah yeah I might hang up some
talented people man damn long brah damn
long and then uh bad babies
howdy I'm doing the damn long thing 101
you're mean to people right look man but
a lot of rats and a world boy and they
need a king you're looking at him
feels lost this guy asking about no I
haven't dude here's the thing brothels
[ __ ] yeah especially if they're well
rent also cops don't be a [ __ ] block man
I don't need you raving them if I'm in
there don't hate on people that the
women get their monies let me bust my
nuts I worked for this cash yeah and
these shlubby reporters who are lonely
as [ __ ] and they want to write
articles Oh Bobby Kraft shouldn't be
getting nut it out over here bastard a
Super Bowl and I get the [ __ ] out of
here if anyone's earned it it's Bobby
Kraft let him get his dick sucked in
Palm Beach Florida after the Super Ball
he owns the place and he only got a
[ __ ]
and if someone's working there who's not
like been brought in on like a train or
like it was not sex slave
yeah didn't let him work you know I'm
saying let him work you know I mean I
don't see why if a woman's a prostitute
she could be president like it doesn't
matter like who cares she's doing that
she's doing a great job let her do what
she wants to do man you know this she SH
love e reporters who have never gotten
any hand jobs and even given one go
solve a real case amen okay dudes
busting nuts paying for it yeah no [ __ ]
she [ __ ] these it's these Twitter
[ __ ] Muppets what I'm saying is get
out there like my boy pain Lindsay and
solve a real-ass murder there you know
gang bro
get me out team Bob let's do me the [ __ ]
out there but obviously King brothels
baby get me out of this before Brendan
puts on a another Jersey if somebody
else that just did something amazing get
me out of here for a steel [ __ ]
hooked up with some other famous
Instagram person try your followers what
else we got well between longneck who's
next dude who's next a bath Barbie video
it's damn long neck you idiot does it
matter he won't be around in a week
again 19 years not really to [ __ ]
brought back down but he's 19 years old
is he really yeah
he's interesting dude man kinda he's
just a kid man he's such a kid ha ha
no I'm gathering a [ __ ] closed area
no [ __ ] the craziest thing I roll up to
the improv right him and he's like hey
here's some squirrels and he hangs out
with right you think you talk about the
mutants that hang around me it's
basically Barnum and Bailey Circus is
like the new circus the fact I think I
don't know that guy that guy's to me
questionable but what was interesting
was seems trust trustworthy he doesn't I
just don't understand what he's doing
hanging out with the youngster but
here's what here's the same thing you
are bro no I think the kid look man
first of all we actually have you know
it's hard to explain but we have a lot
of family lineage no I get it
you're gonna make that so the second
part is though they're outside of the
improv with no shirts on imagine that so
imagine you go to the improv of those
two dudes just milling around with no
shirt but that's something but Dawg I'm
so I'm saying this as real as it gets
they're like less talented Bert
Kreischer that's their thing hey how are
they not Bert's car how are they that
Bert's backup things how do I sell merch
for Bert their shirts off unbelievable
Bert you're welcome great idea dude and
first of all the bunny ranch is where
you need to be at you the chicken right
here Animalia bro you got to move up the
food chain dude chicken you're gonna end
up over there and over there and
Picayune Mississippi which is where I
think they have the largest chicken farm
in America where they make just [ __ ]
processed chicken bro you want to end up
at the bunny ranch you want to get some
you money what's that bunny you want to
get some yeah you want to get some rat
they want that money who trust me you
want that bunny yeah you're gonna end up
just sucking on gizzard bro we want to
thank everybody that came out to our
show to shows yep that was fun it was
fun man there was a lot of fun dude I
wonder if we really like started to put
like all did this but made it live yeah
feel like we could do
we should start to work on it see what
it's like we could be dumped right D
Lane gang never do it live like people
stamp ask what king of sting it live so
they stand up and give us some debates
though or they do videos or something
before they come in here like they bring
their aunts or the punk-ass uncles so
it'll mix up a lot what's up I mix it up
and people even bringing your stupid
dogs or their loving animals whatever
bro you get the point though yeah I get
the point you're it it'd be fun dude
you're a dick that would be fine bring
alright yeah that's it where you gonna
be at dude huh are you gonna be a being
much nicer to people than you are I'll
tell you what you and that girl who's
mean they're a man for being lazy need
to get together that might be your
soulmate couple one two [ __ ] yeah we
in indie this week Thursday Friday
Saturday and then I'm in LA - ville soul
indie to independent bro alone that's
how you're gonna end up so I'm not
surprised your soul man as a family I
have family
yeah bro we're so Janet and you're
jacking off playing [ __ ] Call of Duty
watchin tough [ __ ] on snap [ __ ]
filters or whatever your son keeps
emailing me and tell him he's not really
pleased
so display you know I dude I gotta get
rid of his iPad I knew it I knew it
kept saying uncle Theo Uncle Phil I'm
like like so worried about his email all
the time bro just three wait one meet
where you want to go out you're here we
shave it ahead what are you doing he
wants to gross here out starts talking
about the dark arts right oh all right
man I'll be an indie this week and then
I'm in Nashville in Portland get your
tickets that it brother
that's it man you guys be good thank you
guys for your support
don't touch me but keep [ __ ] to not
touch me
[Music]
nice
[Music]